so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we are four weeks away from the nfl
draft and you know what we do here in
the bleacher report app every thursday
at 1 pm eastern time it's draft crash
course i'm the lead nfl draft analyst
here at bleacher report connor rogers
joined always by stadium's college
football analyst michael felder felder
we got quarterbacks today we got
prophets we got the afc south we got a
lot going on man and finally we can
catch our breath because the nfl
has been a little less crazy these last
couple days how are we feeling right now
man i'm feeling good because uh you know
we got a little bit of a slow down right
we didn't have blood no block no real
blockbuster trades no
no like massive earth moving moment so i
feel good i feel comfortable let's go
ahead we know what we got in this show
we have some specific things to talk
about and because we didn't have any
blockbuster trades i know you went into
the lab and you came up with some trades
and i love this part of it because at
least we can control those trades as we
talk about him on the show today so
let's kick it off if and this is kind of
like if you were the gm
what trades are you going to make let's
kick it off with kansas city
right even after all the free agency
moves all the big blockbusters there are
still defined needs especially for a
couple contenders and i look at the
chiefs as one of those teams so they're
going to take pick 29 let's not forget
they pick back to back in the first
round 29 and 30. they're going to take
29 package it with the newly acquired
50th pick and they're going to call the
texans and say listen we know you need
more capital you're looking to build out
a roster we want to come up to 13
because they want a wide receiver i know
they signed mbs i know they got juju but
they need to be thinking about the next
five to seven years of patrick mahomes
this offense is predicated off of speed
and nobody's got speed in this draft
like jameson williams felder so the
chiefs listen you get to still pick
twice in the first round but you get to
come up and get a premium vertical
threat in jameson williams how do you
like him not only as a player but in
this offense with pat mahomes
well i think he's a great fit because he
can do a little bit of everything right
and that's the cool thing he's really
good at all of the stuff that he does
and he's a guy that's a nuanced route
runner and obviously you see the speed
there he's running away from lsu but
look at this tempo tempo tempo tempo
tempo and now i'm the fastest guy and i
don't think a lot of folks think about
this connor you don't run every route at
full speed what you have to do is set up
things so that you can draw people in
through stemming through leaning and
williams does it really really well and
listen i understand he went to ohio
state first so buckeyes fans please
don't bother me about it i just gave you
the props that you need what i am saying
is that he understands that tempo coming
out of alabama and i think that tempo
goes a long way because it allows you to
use your speed to create a problem
whereas safety's like oh he's running a
dummy route or oh he's going to be
coming back across and then when he
sticks his foot in the ground at the top
of a break or at the top of an you know
when he wants to excel when he stims you
inside on a on a three-quarter tempo
to get wide on a full tempo guess what
you're never gonna catch up to him and i
think that's the beauty of his game love
this trade for them and obviously as you
mentioned with uh houston they they need
to just get a lot of players
yeah that's exactly right i love that
you brought up the changing gears of
jameson williams it's like a pitcher in
baseball that's an ace that can hit 99
100 on the gun but do you have the
change up do you have the breaking ball
and i think with jamison williams he's
so polished in that area which is really
rare for a lot of burners when they come
into the draft and yeah for houston this
is just another way to you can get a
premium player at three you're still
staying in the first round of 29 but
that 50th overall pick as we do this
show every week felder we know how
valuable that 50th overall pick can be
as an extra asset i think the chiefs are
in a position where they can surrender
that so let's keep it moving and look
more in the rebuilding teams category
okay a little comment on the bottom
there i want to say going to need more
than that to trade all the way back to
29. if you look at the trade value chart
i know it's not a perfect science it
does match up somewhat close and you
have to remember in this draft if you're
not coming up for franchise quarterbacks
and we're gonna get to those later if
there are any the cost is not as
significant so this cost will not match
what we've seen over previous years but
definitely a fascinating point right
there all right looking at these
rebuilding teams that might make a move
and and this is one more that i think i
can see happening i don't know if i
necessarily am all aboard moving up for
a quarterback in this class but atlanta
they don't have matt ryan anymore and
the giants they're one of those teams
like the texans looking to build out a
roster so atlanta trying to swap eight
with five get up to five and surrender
pig 58 yes that's a hefty price but you
have to remember they are sniping a
division rival in carolina for a
quarterback here i think carolina is
choosing between kenny pickett and malik
willis atlanta sits there are you really
going to go into the year of marcus
mariota maybe but then you are
essentially admitting that you are in a
tanking a tank-esque rebuilding season
or you can get this thing started now
while also hurting a division opponent
and for the giants you're still picking
at seven anyway then you pick back to
back at seven and eight so felder i'll
throw this to you i'm kind of fascinated
if atlanta or a team like atlanta that
needs a quarterback jumps up to beat the
panthers to the punch
will it be malik willis will it be kenny
pickett should it be malik willis should
it be kenny pickett what do you think in
here
so here's the thing i'm not going to
answer that because we're going to talk
about it later
okay because we're going to get to it
because we're doing quarterbacks this
episode and we're doing prop bets both
of which involve quarterbacks so the
quarterback section involves quarterback
and we're talking prop bets that does
have a quarterback section but for me
yes male equals will be the answer i
think when i look at it and i love the
way that you design that that trade
because listen i i'm from charlotte i
still get the alerts
uh from the charlotte observer every day
the one of the newspapers that i
subscribe to so they are still debating
what they're going to do at that pick
and it's been high controversy
especially for a guy like matt roll
who's trying to save his job they've
said they're gonna start with darnold
but if you come up if they made a deci
if they make a decision on wednesday
night that malik willis is our guy and
then on thursday
the falcons decide hey man
we're taking him and we're going to do
this to get him
they're going to be sitting in no man's
land unless they really love kenny
pickett which again we'll talk about
later and i think that part of it that
that gamesmanship that competitiveness
goes a long way because it's not just
beating out a team for someone this
isn't like if the rams got somebody that
the cowboys want this is
in a division rivals teams that like the
the battle for i-85 like
these teams don't like each other and
being able to do that
especially like
let's fast-forward 10 years and malik
willis is a franchise quarterback and
they jumped ahead of me one spot to get
them
you're gonna feel like trash
yeah
it's all anybody will talk about for all
10 of those years when those teams play
each other so for people that think this
cost might be significant to go up three
spots you need to take into the context
of who they're jumping what they're
doing and what they're getting and for
the giants i know giants fans are
probably like we don't want to move from
five we need a franchise tackle i think
if somebody's jumping you or swapping
with you for a quarterback you're still
getting that player a seven you're still
getting to now pick it eight and you've
got the extra second rounder you're
going to be looking real you're gonna be
sitting real pretty because of joe
shane's uh maneuverability in a couple
years from now so one more trade here
felder before we get to the comment
section that i bet is just popping off
right now let's look at one that's a
little bit more creative in a sense that
it's not the splashy first round move
now this is a bit of a rival trade but
when you're a seattle team that might be
looking to rebuild you need to take
every phone call you can get the niners
are going to go up to 41 they're going
to surrender 61.93 and 134 because
felder they need a safety man this is a
good football team this is a team that
was close to getting to a super bowl
they've lost some players in free agency
they've made some savvy moves you look
at the back end of their defensive
backfield
i love jaquan brisker at 41 felder i
think he is a great athlete he is
interchangeable he can play free he can
play strong this is a move that the
niners yes you're surrendering a lot of
your draft to go get him but you don't
need a lot of things so go up and get an
instant impact player
i love him i like
i i am having such a hard time with the
safeties in this draft and for all the
discussion about quarterbacks and is
this a good tackle draft or whatever i'm
like this is a really good safety draft
and we should be talking more about it
and i think it's it's one we're being
abused by the way that football is shot
on camera because you have to go so far
to find place where the safety's in the
play the whole time but at the same time
that's a personal limitation um but
brisker
i mean
if kyle hamilton's your best safety i
think brian cook's maybe my favorite
safety i think that dax hill is my
favorite player to talk about i think
brisker is
he's the guy i want back to back in a
bar that's the guy i want back to back
and you know what maybe somebody did
something wild and poured a drink on
someone's girlfriend's head but jaquan
brisker brisker's going to stand back to
back with you and you guys are going to
walk out of there alive and everybody
else is going to be limping he is a
bruiser a beast a monster he's so tough
this guy is like broad street bully
i love that about him and and
watching the way that he played through
injury played through
fatigue and still was just like
i got to do this for my team i'm doing
like what is sammy sosa i do this for my
team i do it for my family like that's
what he is like he does that and so he's
that guy i love this trade anybody
that's gonna move up to get brisker i'm
in for it
all right let's take a look at the
comments like i said they are obviously
jumping off m kent one of our power
users always watching the show
appreciate you mcat 93 said
do the titans trade up or down felder i
think when i look at the titans i go
they can use some offensive line help
they're sitting in the back end of round
one the question is do they have to jump
in arizona for one of these top guards
do they have to go even further and get
a tackle
that's going to be a fascinating
situation for them are they going to
make a colossal move to try to go up and
get one of the big three before they're
all gone in the top ten i'll throw this
one to you fella there siller anthony
said do the bills make a move for one of
these top corners maybe sauce or
stingley felder when i look at the
bill's zone heavy scheme what about
trent mcduffie for them or do you like
siller's idea of going way way up for
sauce or stingley
i listen i'm never going to say no to
going up to get a defensive back but i
do think if you can get mcduffie a
little bit later i think that helps you
and he's going to be a guy that comes in
he's scheme versatile he's got the
ability to play he can play zone he can
play man he can play press he can play
off he can he can he he has the ability
to help you in the run game as well
and
that's what i'm looking for i want
someone that can do a lot of different
things
because even though this is a team that
we know they like we know how they like
to play and they do like to play man
they do like to play that that show
press and bale at times i think the big
key here is
finding a guy that if you get a guy that
can do a bunch of different things
get him and i think that's the key
yeah i'm with you all the way felder
we'll do one more from the comments here
before we get into our quarterback
breakdown all right this one from
fly1313
lions should take thibodeaux or trade
down the lions are always in a bad spot
like the akuda year i i think your first
point is more important there fly 133 i
think that you're not in a bad spot
because it too you can get cave on
thibodeau right felder tell them there's
nothing to fear the question is if
they'll do it
he's good this guy's amazing he's so
good if you get him get him like
this could be an opportunity where you
were like you get to laugh at the jags
like realistically like oh look who we
got and then you guys
you guys had passed on because the jack
i think the jaguars are in the most high
pressure situation in this draft because
the player that everybody knows that
they like is aiden hutchinson
and they're going to get him number one
overall but they have the opportunity to
pick any of the 300 and something
players that we we talk about right
so when you miss at that one spot
you can't say well we wanted to get this
other guy so we took this other guy
you have the choice
to make the decision
and if you pass over
thibodeau you pass him over somebody
else gets him and he becomes a superstar
who made the mistake
you
man it's it's crazy to think about and
honestly the closer we get to this draft
uh it's it could be reality i saw the
comments section on the sidebar they're
jumping off about the packers they pick
at 22 and 28. i'm with you guys i think
they can move up and get a wide receiver
here here's one for you felder would you
stay
tuned timeout i'm out out time out do
they have to move up to get a wide
receiver that's getting a while
getting a wide receiver at 22 or 28 or
at 22 and 28 that's more than they would
have done already
for aaron rodgers right yep
so it's a matter of
do you think a christian watson can be
there i don't think a chris alave will
be there green bay's got to decide are
we okay with the second tier of this
wide receiver class which is pretty damn
good to be honest with you or do we want
to go all the way up for jamison
williams as we saw in our earlier mock
situation chiefs do but
let's get into these quarterbacks so we
have a lot of time for the comments
today we got quarterback talk once again
we got draft prop talk i know you guys
love the prophets for the draft and
we're going to break down the afc south
as well so if you have more questions
whether it's packers throw anything in
the comment section we'll get to it
belder let's get into these quarterbacks
and we have to start with the projected
top picks right we're going to do a lot
of different tiers today the athletic
guys the big arm pocket passers the
accurate players but
we got to start with the big two that we
we know they're going in the uh first
round they could go in the top 10 at
this point it's been a huge climb and
we're going to start with malik willis
here right when you look at malik willis
we talked about it earlier for a team
like atlanta to try to jump the panthers
to go get him felder i have to be honest
with you from malik willis i really
struggled coming up with a player
comparison for him he's a unique player
he obviously
is mobile and a good runner but he's not
a lamar jackson kind of runner that's
not his game he's got a howitzer of an
arm and everything is starting to come
together and when i compared him to a
player like cordell stewart i kind of
thought in this era of the nfl cordell
stewart would be an even better kind of
player so that's a compliment uh not an
insult to malik willis's game but for
you felder what have you seen from malik
willis not just you know from going from
auburn to liberty but the projected top
10 pick he is now
i think when you go back to the comps i
like if i was going to comp i'm going
he's like um like great value equate
like vic who
got to play in this era versus the pro
style era you know what i mean where
big arm vic had a huge arm people don't
know about this but vic had a map people
forget about this but vic had a massive
arm i think if he played if michael vick
played today he would be like wow this
is insane let's stop and yeah
be unreal and so i think that's the part
the arm is the part that i'm comparing
to vic not the legs the legs part is a
little bit more
goodness it's like jeff garcia like i
guess this is like if jeff garcia and
and michael vick had a kid like
he he he's slippery enough to be a
problem but he's not like he's not steve
young he's obviously not vic he's not
lamar jackson so i to me that next level
of slippery is jeff garcia and so i
would throw him into that mix but jeff
garcia had little
pea shooter he this guy's got that vic
huge arm to get the ball down the field
the big thing i see when i look at malik
wilson the reason i think he's gonna be
the first quarterback on the board is
his ability to always keep his eyes
downfield and that ability to track is
important uh we see guys like russell
wilson have that ability obviously i
think roethlisberger is another guy that
not super mobile but super big and
ability and able to
evade and then get his eyes back
downfield and make plays i think he has
that quality of always knowing where his
guys are going to come open i love the
play against virginia tech from i
believe two seasons ago where he spins
out to evade and then he hits a guy
drops a dime at the one yard line
and keeps him in bounds just barely but
keeps him in bounds to make a play so
for me that's why i have him i think
he's the best quarterback in this group
he's super talented uh by all accounts
and and you could talk to me more about
this because you're at the combine and
obviously you've talked to folks who've
talked to him and you've seen what he's
able to do you're a senior bowl
people like him he's got an infectious
personality
and so yeah like just i think putting
all those things together they put him
in prime position here
yeah i think that's really important is
what you do off the camera and that's
the the board work and being the face of
the franchise the guy that after every
loss has to be on the podium answering
questions for what went wrong and malik
willis is that kind of person that you
can put that level of trust in and
that's probably the biggest compliment
you can give any player before the nfl
draft and it's why it's one of many
reasons but i think it's what got malik
willis from
great athlete huge arm like you know
obviously
um all the talent in the world to bona
fide top 10 pick we believe in him as
the future of our franchise and that's
how he's going to be drafted it starts
at two with the lions it could be the
panthers at six and then it'll get real
interesting from after that and speaking
of getting interesting kenny pickett the
other top flight quarterback in this
trap honestly felder
it couldn't be more opposite in the kind
of mold of the prospect he is he's not
just this you know slow-footed pocket
passer he can move but kenny pickett is
more of the pinpoint window thrower get
the ball out accurate you know can
obviously move and manipulate the pocket
at times but kenny pickett's highs
remind me of derek carr and that's once
again derek carr is a really good
quarterback in the nfl right now
that for a second round pick has
exceeded expectations by a mile and for
kenny pickett he's somebody that plays
in a similar style has a similar body
type and athleticism mold and people are
going to love his ability to come in and
run the offense right away that high
floor kind of player and that's why when
it's all said and done he's a lock to go
in the top 20 but it wouldn't be
shocking to me if somebody moved in the
top 15 to get him so felder this is
someone who has really developed a pit
shocking like he's an older prospect i
think he'll be a 24 year old rookie but
the steps he's taken even from 2020 to
2021 have been monumental
you know i i love kenny pickett and it's
it's a testament to development and i
think that's the really cool part about
it is watching him his ability to go
from i mean this is a guy that he might
have ran more than any college football
player earlier in his career when they
had to run to the sideline every single
play to get the play and then bring the
play in do the play in the huddle do the
play then run back to the sideline to
get the play go back like it was very
high school hairy some of the things
that he was doing but i think the cool
thing about what he does is his ability
to
make anticipatory throws
and
he is someone and i've said this before
but he
he looks like matt ryan but plays a lot
more like russell wilson and
i have no problem putting this on wax
for everyone to hear he is the fastest
player in the country
when it comes to getting to the
sidelines there is no one faster than
kenny pickett when it comes time to get
to the sidelines he will beat your
linebacker he will beat your safety he
will beat your corner he will get to the
sidelines in a hurry because he
understands how to protect himself we
always talk about the um the fake slide
and the whole deal but i think the
reality of it with him is he understands
the best thing that i can do is be in
the game and if i have to make sure i'm
protecting myself i'm going to stay in
the game so i love what he brings in
that regard also he's he's played in an
nfl system and there's no two ways about
that he's playing in an nfl system he is
playing for an nfl offensive coordinator
he knows what he's doing he understands
how to get there he understands when the
guys come open he understands when to
make those throws and that's something
that a lot of folks are going to
appreciate and that's something that i
appreciate about him
because watching him play is like
putting on essentially a clinic it's
okay i have a four there's four four
guys in this route
he's not open right now he's not open
okay oh no
different coverage on the back side what
do i have to do oh got it i have to i
have to wait for this guy to clear now i
can hit him please and then he'll sit
you down and i think that's the why
that's why for me he becomes valuable as
an asset to your franchise because he
understands
coverages
and
when guys are supposed to be open which
goes back to our jamieson william point
right about tempoing routes and how
things work i think it's the same thing
you see the comment there from alonzo
soto who says pick it reminds me of
dalton will have a good career but not
great that can carry a team and i think
that's a fair comment i think when it
comes down to it it gets not in the mold
of some of the prospects we've seen over
the years that you know it's the old
tractor or trailer essentially situation
are you gonna drive the team or are you
along for the ride and
sometimes there's nothing wrong with
that it's just a matter of where you go
and if you have the right infrastructure
to succeed so that'll be really
important for kenny pickett but we got a
lot of quarterbacks to go through so
let's keep this thing moving and go
really in a sense to a different tier
this is our big arm quarterbacks here
felder and we're going to start with sam
howell who might not be the biggest
quarterback but the arm is real the
velocity i believe is the you know some
of the fastest they saw at the combine
this year uh at the senior bowl
obviously uh who he had an up and down
throwing performance at the senior bowl
but sam howell you never have to worry
about the arm strength with him we've
seen him make plays with his legs i
thought 2020 when he had a better
supporting cast he had a cleaner year as
a passer at this time he had to you know
this year it felt like he had to play
some hero ball at times a lot of running
from the pocket plays breaking down
looking to make that play with his legs
and once again a lot of that is the town
around him but felder for me this is
somebody i project to go
more in the top 75 of the draft not the
first round of the draft where do you
see sam howell's nfl career projection
and really what he does best right now
yeah i'm right there with you i think
he's a guy that's gonna end up on day
two which is gonna be interesting uh the
cool thing for him and for folks that
don't know this is a guy that was
committed to florida state florida state
goes through a little bit of turmoil unc
gets a new coach and he decides to stay
at home he's from um not from charlotte
so don't let anybody get it twisted he
is from union county went to sun valley
high school that's not in charlotte just
so you know and he is someone though
that and it's interesting you mentioned
he had to play a hero ball right in 20
um 2021 but you see him there he's able
to play hero ball he's able to break
tackles he's able to make plays
and
i thought about putting him into the
athleticism category but his arm is just
so good again you see him here he gets
tagged by a guy don't worry i'm scoring
and then you see him giving the guy the
business letting people know about it he
is
super talented
the question becomes can he throw
between the hash marks can he throw into
the interior of the field because so
much of his work and i know we're going
to talk carson strong as well but so
much of his work was vertical to the
edges
and that's where
you make highlights but
in between the hatches is where you make
first downs the first downs lead to
touchdowns and that's the part where we
need to see him really improve and and
the other part about it
as you mentioned that hero ball
this guy ran for 800 yards almost 900
yards
like this guy ran for a lot of yards a
year ago and
he is willing to do it and that includes
the sax so if you take the sacks out he
probably ran for a thousand yards
and he's amazing at being able to be
tough to to win at the point to do those
things which gives him the ability and i
think for me i think on day two uh conor
he becomes someone that
hey
we feel good about him we we like him we
just got to teach him how to do
these things that they aren't teaching
on college offenses right now phil longo
didn't impart him with these skills so
if we can teach him to do that
maybe it's an alex smith type situation
right where once he got
to learn football and learn a little bit
more especially between the hashes he
got better i think he's in that same
camp where you have to ask him to do a
little bit more but all he had to do in
college to win was throw the ball deep
and then run
yeah i think you nailed it felder i
think the question is to what you're
saying can he learn how to paper cut a
defense right the the eight to ten yard
eight to 15 yard throws in the middle of
the fields that keep you on the field uh
keep the defense on the field tire them
out and sustain drives at the nfl
because
most of the time that is the nfl game
and and i think howell has a chance to
improve that you see the comment there
sam howell as russell wilson you know i
would always be honest on this show i
get away from comps that are super rich
i think he's case keenum with a stronger
arm and a lot of people will take that
in a real negative way case kingdom has
come in started in spurts and really
ignited his team to wins in big spots
and i think hal plays with that fiery
mentality and energy as well that i'm
excited to see and i saw somebody
connect him to the titans in here i
actually think that's a tremendous fit
behind tannehill let tana hill's running
money run out in the next couple years
and hal will get his shot if he's ready
to go all right let's keep this thing
moving
the offense that much
exactly it's the same kind of thing
especially with the run heavy approach
they have it'll help a young quarterback
there our next big armed quarterback is
carson strong he is
you know not gonna move like the three
guys we've talked about malik willis
kenny pickett obviously sam howell but
belder this guy's got a howitzer he's
got a bazooka and you know you watch the
nevada offense with romeo dubs and cole
turner
they were not afraid to get this thing
going they love to push the ball
vertically down the field so i look at
carson strong obviously the knee injury
in the past has been something of a
concern for teams but it sounds like
medically he's checked out okay and he
is a classic drop back let me hit all
three levels of the field but i really
really like these 20-plus yard throws so
he's a little old-school felder what do
you think of carson strong who's just
been tremendous for that nevada program
i loved watching him play the last
couple seasons he was kind of like my
one of my like hidden gems of just oh
watch this guy throw the ball because
he's going to
launch it and he still has a pretty
tight release which i really like like
it doesn't take him hours and we'll talk
about somebody that takes an hour to
throw the football a little bit later
but i love that part of his game and but
carson's strong like are you going to
tell me that john elway is not sitting
there like hey man this is
this guy this could be my guy he could
be the guy
so i think there's going to be
old school folks who really like the
idea of
drop back throw far that are gonna fall
in love with him i don't think they fall
in love with him to the tune of the
first round which is something that we
flirted with um in the first half of the
college football season and then kind of
fell off uh as we watch things happen
but carson's strong man
big tree fall hard like this guy will
go back there he will throw it as far as
he can he's gonna be the other part is
he's remarkably accurate in his deep
throws and i think that's a testament to
someone who is not just you know closing
their eyes and winging it it's someone
who understands
the the complex calculations that it
takes to put the ball on your wide
receiver where the defensive back is
throw them to the side if they're open
throw them to the sideline if you need
to get them open and i think he does all
those things really really well again i
think he's probably a day two guy and i
think it's gonna take someone who just
a coach that gets enamored with the idea
of i can fix him and you and i talked
about this on what tape don't lie right
the idea of a scout or a coach a
positional coach a coordinator that's
like
i can i can get him to where i need him
to be
i can't like you're never going to teach
kitty picking to throw the ball as far
as carson strong
you're never going to teach someone
desmond ritter to throw the ball as far
as carson strong so if that's the thing
that you really really like
get him now because you think you t you
can teach him to do some of the other
little things right
to me felder he's in the mold of a chad
henny who people might laugh at that
when they hear that name chad had he's
been in the nfl for about 14 years so if
carson strong plays in the nfl for 14
years
he'll be doing just fine all right let's
take a break for the comments before we
move on to our next quarterback category
m kenton here giving felder's beard some
love saying it's looking as strong as
ever he also said carson strong will be
a bust 200 percent it depends what you
ask of him here i think i project carson
strong as a top 100 pick and a long term
backup if you want him to be your
franchise saver uh yeah you're probably
going to be disappointed crump 150 ways
says strong is drew bledsoe fell they're
a little bit more of a rich comp than me
but i think that play style hits i like
it crump 150 way to get in on the player
comparison uh game that we are always
rolling here on crash course so we got a
loaded show i love the comments but we
got to keep this moving here felder it's
time for a little athleticism at the
quarterback position and
yes we know malik willis has it we know
kenny pickett and sam howell have it but
these guys it's a little bit of their
calling card let's start with matt
corral who i project to go in the top 40
of this draft a rhythm thrower in my
osfelder you get him moving in the
offense yes a lot of it in that ole miss
offense is first read if it's there i'm
gonna let it rip if it's not i'm gonna
run so i i think you know you don't
wanna use that as an insult because a
lot of quarterbacks in college football
play in that kind of offense and a lot
in the nfl are playing in that offense
these days as well so i think with
corral he might have the highest ceiling
of any quarterback not in the first two
we did in the show the question is with
his running can that body type stay
healthy and can he
limit the risk he takes felder i think
with corral on tape there's times where
you're like i love your gunslinger
mentality i love your attitude to go out
and win the game and you see right there
exactly what i talked about earlier but
belder i just think he's a little wild
with the football sometimes
he has a tremendous arm and he believes
in that arm
in a big way and so
because he can do that and this is going
back to high school like i remember
watching him we were out in oregon and
watching him just be like no i can fit
it in and it's just and you see it there
look at that he shouldn't have made that
throw three guys were around them don't
make that throw but he does it anyways
because he knows that he can and listen
if it succeeds 65 of the time you're
going to be happy with it and i think
that's going to be the question mark
about matt corral but super talented
super athletic didn't realize how
athletic he was until he got to ole miss
because so much of what he did was
throwing the football i'm gonna kick
another one back to you and i'm gonna go
desmond ritter because he's someone that
i think matt corral might throw people
for a loop because so many people think
about him as a passer but desmond ritter
is kind of the
the quote-unquote athletic qb of this
class
for better or for worse but when you
look at him
he's someone
i think the coaching is the next thing
for him i think he makes good layered
throws
i think that he has the ability to
obviously beat you with his legs as
we're seeing right here
but i think
the key for him is all going to be
between the ears because i think he can
do everything you want a quarterback to
do it's just a matter of him managing
his own emotions and frustration
i think so too felder i think with
ritter you know you look at the testing
numbers that he put up at the combine
you almost want to see him
play more like an athlete and use that
athleticism more in his game to maybe
open up some of the passing windows that
he struggles with at times and ritter
has
all the necessary talent to be a
starting quarterback it's you know he
has the body type the arm the
athleticism uh the understanding of the
offense i think the biggest thing for me
felder that goes back to what you just
said he just needs to play faster there
he's a four-year starter and he's just
it the play clock has not gotten to
where you expect it to be after starting
in four years played for a program in
cincinnati who was just in the college
football playoff they've played in some
big time football games they've played
at a high level i think there's just
times where he's a step slow and maybe
some of it is his release but some of it
is also just diagnosing and playing at a
certain speed where he's allowing
defenders to see things so ritter's
going to get drafted in the top 50 and
he's going to get drafted as a future
starter the question is can a coaching
staff build the right offense for him
that starts to display a little bit more
of that athleticism while the passing
game speeds up
yeah i i love that i love that
assessment of it all i think that the
key for me is
understanding you know what the offense
is asking of you and how to do it
another guy that we have in our
athleticism category skyler thompson
because
i truly think that he fits into this one
super athletic people don't acknowledge
his athleticism because he played it
like kansas state but the reality of it
is is this guy's a little bit wily he's
a little bit slippery finds a way to to
he finds a way to steal yards uh if i
was gonna do a cop i'd go connor shaw
how about that
oh nice fella
yeah but he makes throws when he has to
make throws he's made these throws and
he has these weird games and connor you
listen you i'm doing this week to week
on saturdays just watching this based on
the college football world
what is it what do you think when you
watch some of these weird games where he
kind of just shows up and it just makes
throws like this down the field where
you're like
when did you where was that at the game
before
that's exactly right builder that's my
frustration with skyler thompson and you
saw the draft project projection i think
he'll be a priority udfa i don't know if
he hears his name called in this draft
but
there's flashes where you go the arm is
there the touch throws down the field
are there
why are you not throwing the ball some
weeks there's some weak spell there
where he just doesn't want to let the
football go and i you always got to be
careful in you know criticizing that of
a guy's game because there is is there a
coach in their ear that says
we don't care what you do for us just
don't make mistakes if you think there's
a chance that there's going to be a
mistake made
do not throw the ball live to make
another play the next down the next
drive unfortunately for skylar thompson
a lot of times it was the next week and
i think
that is something to me that makes him
one of the hardest projections out of
all of these guys because like you said
there are flash plays he will definitely
get an nfl camp he'll get to utilize and
show off that arm at least as a camp
body can he hang on to a practice squad
and get a chance to hang on to the
league i think we've seen glimpses of
talent to show that he can alright let's
get to the comments real quick before we
go to the pinpoint accuracy guys uh of
this draft we got a lot of different
comments coming in
juggalo one says matt corral is this
year's mac jones all right juggalo i
think that's uh that seems like a lot of
praise right there growl could sneak
into round one i wouldn't deny that the
question is is he gonna play right away
that part would surprise me e callahan
is on board with that too says matt
crowl could be the steal of the draft
big uh bighorn 77 said corral is mariota
that was my player comp on the show i
agree with you he's smaller though than
marcus mariota so he needs to be careful
with that running because that body type
cannot take the same kind of hits uh
mariota has a couple inches and some
weight on him as well so
all right let's keep it moving right
here we got the pinpoint accuracy
quarterbacks we're going to start with
bailly zappy felder if people watching
the show have not watched him play all
you have to do is google the production
to see the kind of insane stats he got
to show off at
not just western kentucky but he
transferred from houston baptist this
guy playing with jarrett stearns at both
schools threw for a mammoth amount of
yards
i mean the numbers are insane over 60
touchdowns it's unbelievable what he's
able to do one two three oh and he you
see it right there like he's a rhythm
thrower he is someone that gets to the
top of his drop takes a beat lets it go
knows where this wouldn't he knows where
the guy's going to come open knows when
he's supposed to come open and then he
puts the ball right on him and i love
the fact especially as we watch him and
we talked about sam howell not throwing
to that interior right this guy loves to
eat up the interior with slant with
those digs with some crosses he
understands when where guys are going to
come open and i mean what a remarkable
experiment right bringing over
a staff and a quarterback a wide
receiver all that from houston baptist
to make western kentucky a formidable
foe really was really it's very cool
interesting cool to watch and so
zappy he's got to be first on our list
for accuracy by the numbers but also by
what he's able to do
yeah he's not going to stretch the field
in any sense but he's a guy that can be
that pinpoint thrower as a long-term
backup once again all right let's keep
this thing moving
e.j perry next up an ivy league
quarterback originally started at boston
college i believe when he transferred to
brownfelder it was to play for his uncle
which is very very interesting transfer
here for ej perry when i look at him
he's very specific in what offense he
has to go to now obviously a team like
baltimore has a really good long-term
backup in tyler huntley but that's what
i'm thinking somebody that you can get
him moving you can run rpo with him you
can use him legitimately in the run game
and keep that short area passing attack
open for ej perry so felder this is
someone that has a shot to go at the end
of the draft seventh round we're looking
at you see the roll out there his game
is developed off of that short area
throwing and the ability to do it on the
move
yeah it's it's back shoulder it's short
area it's the the rpo game it's all
those little things and i like i love
him throwing the ball from 11 yards down
uh on a quick when he's also working a
run fake in his ability to flip his hips
is really uh i find to be remarkable and
that's something i don't think a lot of
folks talk about but he can give you a
pass fake to his to his right
flip his hips open to get the ball back
to the left because he knows that
linebacker is taking a step inside i
think he fits along with another guy
that we have in there right caleb ellaby
in he's from what western michigan and
he he does a lot of they these two guys
to me feel very similar am i crazy for
thinking that because i think they both
have this ability to
work
really quick in that tight game to
create plays and ultimately the goal for
your quarterback is to be a point guard
get the ball to your playmakers to make
plays and if you can get it to their
hands faster yet they got opportunity to
do more
yeah i think you nailed it felder when
you look at ella b play and you know a
little bit of a surprise underclassmen
declaration a smaller guy
a lot of these quarterbacks are right
around six one six feet tall 200 210
pounds he's someone that is going to try
to you know layer the field with touch
throws at all three levels i think he
moves well he dominated in that
conference i think there's times when
the heat gets turned up and you could
see this when he played michigan
obviously a higher level of competition
he started to aim a little bit rather
than throw but when you see him get time
and the offense obviously opens up for
him you're seeing him go out there and
comfortably spray the ball around jump
in here felder what have you seen with
elevate yeah i want to say can we i
don't know i don't know if we can do
this but can we run that clip back again
specifically we can cut it after the
pittsburgh play but i want folks to look
at what this what happens here if we run
back ella because this is what i'm
talking about with flipping the hips
it's
remarkable the the speed the pass it's
the play after this so i'll wait to get
to it but his ability to flip his hips
we see it out of out of here it is right
here look at this now get my hips back
and get reset to make this throw to the
interior that's hard to do and so i
think a lot of folks don't realize that
that's something when it comes to rhythm
passing when it comes to quickness and
accuracy it's really hard to do the back
went the wrong way on the fake but he
still got his hips flipped
and was able to get the ball to that
slant he can do it zappy can do it uh ej
perry him and ej perry are really good
at it that's what i like about him
so i wanted to get that in there connor
you going to take us to the questions
are we going to finally end up on these
wild cards
let's get to the wild card quarterbacks
and then we'll dive into the comments
because i know we got those rolling in
as we get through all of these
quarterbacks in a really interesting
class here
brock purdy felder i'll let you take
this one away you've watched him for a
long time this is the wild cards right
here these guys
long shots to be drafted even long shots
to hang on in the league for a long time
but if you look at brock purdy felder
what's the calling card trait that you
think can keep him around the nfl for a
bit
i thought he was going to be a
first-round draft pick after his
freshman year but this is what i think
is going to be what keeps him in
his under his trust of his players
there's a trust and understanding
obviously you see a little bit of the
athleticism but the trust that he has in
his teammates whether it's charlie
kohler any of these uh bruce hall
obviously his ability to understand that
even when they're not open they're open
and that's something you have to have in
the nfl
and his ability to buy time with the
legs to make plays down the field so for
me i think brock party's still a viable
solution is not the right word i'm not
going to call him a viable solution i am
going to say that he is a viable option
at the quarterback spot uh he's someone
who's going to be remarkable remarkably
serviceable and
ultimately can kind of you mentioned the
case keenum comp for for for sam howe i
think that brock party feels to me at
least like like a plushed up tj yates
and listen i love tj with all my heart
truly as a friend so i think this is a
little a plused up tj a guy that listen
won a playoff game for the texans so
let's go
all right let's keep the wild cards
moving i'm rolling with the keel glass
right here from alabama a m a two-time
captain a huge player at the position
he's about six foot five carries that
weight well obviously still developing
but monster numbers this year for
alabama a m here felder i was a little
surprised a little hurt that he wasn't
invited to the nfl combine because this
is somebody that you look at and go
i would stash him on the practice squad
and develop him and see what i have
because of the upside that he has was he
asked to be a hero all the time in that
offense not necessarily but does he do a
good job dropping the ball in like ella
b as you see right here that's the name
of his game drop back if i don't have to
move i'm gonna give my guy a chance and
put the ball where only he can get it so
akeel glass is someone that despite not
getting that combine invite i wouldn't
be shocked to see him hear his name
called off the board in round seven and
as we rounded this thing out you tease
that early felder cole kelly akil glass
and cole kelly nflpa bowl uh players
this year for the draft which is a good
sign for them having a shot at getting
drafted you hinted at a quarterback that
loads up like a bazooka takes forever to
throw the ball i know you followed cole
kelly for a long time what have you seen
in his game felder he's a giant at the
position
he's humongous
but it takes him forever to throw the
football and that's the part that's
interesting
he doesn't have like you see it right
there like that wasn't slow-motion this
is slow motion the other part was just
him throwing
it takes him a long time and so you
wonder
how long he's gonna have to develop and
how long people can you shorten up that
delivery what can you do with it i think
is it the big question
but this is that's the way he throws the
football and that's why he's comfortable
throwing the football so we'll see what
happens with cole kelly a guy out of um
southeast louisiana it's going to be
interesting
connor take us to the comments so we can
get to this divisional breakthrough man
our division will break down not break
through
let's let's fire away here we got the
real gm says ej perry the pride of
andover massachusetts uh krump 150 says
zappy is colt brennan alonso soto's back
and said
we're talking about a projected seventh
round quarterback shows how weak this
quarterback class is yes alonso that is
exactly right and we got uh krump is
back with the player comps there says
purdy is mark bulger
all right let's get into the divisional
breakdown the comments uh i've been
bringing it today i like the player comp
suggestions here before we get to the
divisional breakdown felder we gotta do
play we gotta do player props we gotta
do draft props let's stick with the
quarterbacks let's kick it off here
first quarterback off the board we know
it's a two-man race here felder who do
you like
i'm going malik willis listen i'm not a
gambler i don't gamble i don't even know
a lot of the gambling terminology
so i'm just gonna keep my money in my
pocket and go malik willis i think he's
the first one off the board what about
you
i'm gonna roll with kenny pickett and
only because of the plus money i think
malik with us there minus 200 yes he's
the favorite yes he probably even if
it's not number two he can go sixth
overall he can go in a trade-up scenario
i'll take kenny pickett's plus money
plus 175 for kenny pickett and a little
bit of a surprise
this one not as interesting not as tight
first running back off the board breeze
hall for me felder i'm not going to
overthink this minus 250 a heavy heavy
favorite he's in my top 30 players i
don't have a running back after that
until about 49 for kenneth walker freeze
hall is a stud he's a workhorse i think
he comes in and starts right away as a
workhorse back for an nfl team are you
rolling with me on this one felder
yeah we're listen we're in lock step on
this one i think it's going to be
interesting to see when the running
backs come off the board in this strap
obviously we expect breeze to be the
first one off but when we you talk about
these other guys whether it's damian
pierce or we talk about obviously
kenneth walker
ty chandler from unc all these guys are
like kind of
clustered together after breeze and i
think it's going to be interesting where
they fit
all right a little bit more of an
interesting one not as cut and dried
wide receiver first wide receiver off
the board garrett wilson's the favorite
i'm going to go with the runner up drake
london plus 135 i like that plus money i
said atlanta could trade up earlier in
the show if they don't i think drake
london can go off the board at eight i
think he can go off the board at 10 to
the new york jets above the rim receiver
obviously number one potential i've
heard a little bit of a rumor even if he
doesn't run he was projected to log
about a 4 5 7 40 which would be a great
time at his size and you see the
basketball ability on the field so
felder i know you like drake london but
i know you like someone else for first
wide receiver off the board
yeah i i like drake london i love
jamison williams
so i'm gonna roll with him i think
garrett wilson is really good i like
crystal lobby i love johan dotson i
think these guys are all good but i'm
gonna go jamison williams i think he's
just the guy that even coming off injury
we're talking about the crazy thing here
is we're talking about two guys that are
both coming off injuries and we still
think that they're going to go above the
guy garrett wilson who's
healthy and folks are going to get has
got to see him play finish out the
entire season so i'm going jamison
williams on this one uh and you know
what i'm going to stick with this one we
we also have offensive lineman on the
prop 4 connor and i'm going to stick at
alabama baby first offensive lineman off
the board
evan neal i'm taking him let's go
felder rod in the juice here he has
jamison williams plus 850 evan neal plus
105. that'd be serious return on your
investment i gotta roll with my boy ikea
kwan who first wide receiver uh
offensive lineman off the board minus
120 so the payout not as good
but when you look at icky here man i
think he's going number three overall to
the texans i know they got laramie
tonsille i know they've used picks over
the euros on the line that were not made
by nick casario
felder i think they're just going to
want a big bad bully to reset this
franchise the new england way and i
think quantum is going to fit that mold
but man you see how close those odds are
between him and evan neal it is going to
be fascinating to see which offensive
lineman and which wide receiver comes
off the board first i know
i know the bleacher for viewers love the
comment love the draft props
there can keep those comments rolling to
see what they're going with on your
local sports book but here we have it
quarterbacks running backs wide
receivers offensive lineman first to
come off the board all right before we
get out of here we always do a
divisional breakdown we're showing you
love all right we got the comments
coming offensive rookie of the year race
is going to be fun this year says c
mcculla i agree it's going to be pretty
wide open it's going to be based on
landing spots juan's a soda do you think
at least five wide receivers go in the
first round felder we got time for this
one
i think absolutely i think i would take
the over jump in felder so we got what
are we we got london
olave
wilson
williams
who am i am i forgetting somebody
berks yeah it could be it also
could be datsun at the back end
christian watson yeah yeah
yeah yeah so yeah yeah
boom
all right divisional breakdown we got
the afc south on tap this week
felder brought it he's got players
galore for us on the afc south and we
are
we're done looking at these first
rounders every single week we're getting
into the nitty gritty i mean we are four
weeks out from the nfl draft here are
your team needs let's start with the
titans they got nina linebacker they
could still use another wide receiver we
talked about that offensive line earlier
in the show
belder i know you have your eyes on not
one but two linebackers in this group
who do you like
so i one i love nicoby dean if you're
going to get a linebacker in the first
round let's go get in the kobe do you
well here's a question do you think
he'll be around when they pick at like
26
i do i think the fact that
he he didn't test and i've heard a
little bit of her rumors that he was
really banged up and that wasn't out
there but it's that's why he's not
hiding anything he's an athlete okay
everybody's making this assumption that
he won't test well but he's a smaller
guy builder and the shorter linebackers
in this league
typically have to wait to hear their
name called a little longer so i do
think home make it to the end of round
one
so and then i gotta go if we're going a
little bit deeper we're gonna go picks
131 169-ish cordell flot from lsu and i
think that that's another opportunity to
get a guy the question is going to be
what's the positioning look like as a
guy that plays some inside corner some
outside corner what is it what does his
positioning look like at the next level
and can he do something besides play man
yeah it's a great point felder it's a
matter of and you know for that team
they don't even need him necessarily to
live on the outside but i like your
defensive minded approach for a team
that's had a lot of injuries at that
spot obviously the rashan evans pick did
not work out when you start with
linebacker when the kobe dean and flot
is more of that value pick for their
secondary later on in the draft as you
said you're looking out outside the top
100 uh that's where he's projected to go
a lot of upside in that selection as
well with fly all right let's move on to
the texans you saw it earlier
quarterback offensive line edge safety
wide receiver linebacker needs galore on
this roster
felder i know you want to start in the
trenches for this team i brought up icky
earlier at number three if they don't go
that route who do you like for them
outside of round one
well you know i've talked about tweeners
before i think darren kennar becomes an
interesting prospect right because
do they pick him at what is that pick 37
start towards the top of the second
round you pick someone who
has played tackle but might be better at
guard and then you figure out what to do
with him because he's maybe the best
lineman available on the board what do
you think about that
i love it felder i think it's the right
landing spot too he's somebody that
is not going to go in the first 25 picks
he might not have the feet to survive at
tackle but you get into camp and you
find out and you really think if he
doesn't he's not able to protect that
edge you can kick him inside and you
have one of the best impact run blockers
in the entire draft for a team that they
had the worst run game in the nfl last
year so it's got to get better for the
texans there and then we know besides
brandon cooks they've been shrouding out
borderline roster players at wide
receiver so i know you had one in store
here for one of their later picks who do
you like to add to this
desperate wide receiver group
jaylen naylor from michigan state this
is one of those things that's gonna make
my wife my wife is this my wife is a
spartan
her cousin was her cousin was a starting
left tackle for them for a few years
they love sparty there jalen naylor to
me is a really interesting player
because i wonder how fast he actually is
in games there are times where he looks
explosive but then there's other times
where he can't seem to get the
separation that he wants and a lot of
that is dependent upon the defensive
back that he's playing against so
against rutgers yeah sure i'm wide open
but then he gets michigan i we've got to
scheme me open and
so i guess where do you think he fits
because right here he's not open on that
play against iowa but
he does find ways based on the throw
based upon body movement to create space
i think he's a crafty wide receiver
we've talked about that with datsun we
talked about it with jamison williams i
think he's crafty in that sense to find
a way to get open i don't know how much
that translates to the nfl but like how
high can he be picked and do you think
he's an asset
to the um to the texans
yeah i think you're looking at the fifth
round for him felder which we've seen
fifth round wide receivers hang on in
the nfl for a long time and make an
impact now he ran a 4540 at the combine
and i think that makes perfect sense
very average speed at his size the 38
inch vertical though is a good time for
his explosive nature and that showed up
to me on film this year the ability to
be a more explosive threat down the
field for that offense is what stuck out
and naylor was one of my surprises of
the season when i got eyes on him in
about october i looked at it and go you
know for somebody that could have went
back to school he's going to be drafted
and he's not waiting till the sixth or
seventh round or having to sign in the
udfa process so
he's one of the more uh bargain related
wide receivers in the strap builder
that's not getting enough love and i
think he plays a tough guy game which
does matter so much at the next level he
he will mix it up as a blocker if you
need to trust your wide receivers to
block on the outside he'll bring that as
well so jalen naylor glad to get him
involved on the show the texans need to
remake that room and it's not all going
to be first and second round players at
that position all right jacksonville we
saw this team spend
an unbelievable amount of money in free
agency but they also have big time picks
one overall first overall 33rd overall
the top of the second round where you
can get one of those first rounders that
fell they need d-line they need wide
receivers still maybe linebacker or
safety this is a team that still has a
lot of long-term needs
felder i i already know because i could
see the rundown the direction you're
going for them at defensive back this is
one of my favorite players in the draft
so break it down
yeah i daxton hill is remarkable to
watch if they can get him at 33
run don't walk and get that card in you
see him here on the blitz okay he can
blitz you see him here playing levels as
an inside corner no problem and then
sinking into coverage to make an
interception oh wow he can play zone or
man you see him here coming across the
formation and still outrunning a guy to
stop the first down he does everything i
literally sat down today and drew up
multiple plays you look at this look at
that
ah a little bit of slice coverage i love
that that's the stuff that that's what i
love about football like his versatility
is amazing his ability is amazing he's
what people thought jabril peppers was
going to be he's what people thought
jabril peppers was he is
a true safety that can play at free
safety and you've mentioned it before
conor he he's lined up at free safety
he's lined up an inside corner he's
lined up at outside corner he's lined up
at strong safety he can do everything so
at 33 if you're the jags at 33 and he's
on the board are you not running that
card in
it's the easiest pick you can make in
that spot if he's 33 for jacksonville 35
for the new york jets he's going in the
top 40. when you look at those teams
that are picking in that range that need
safeties on the back end and felder we
talked about this on your podcast
they've done a lot he's just such a good
dynamic athlete that you trust him
anywhere he can be a match-up player
against bigger tight ends in the slot he
can play too high i think he can play
single high he's just that athletic uh
he's intense
he really stood out on a michigan
defense that when aiden hutchinson and
david ajaba were getting all that love
there was somebody on the back end like
you said you can't always see it on the
tv tape but on that coach's tape you
could see it with daxton hill he's an
excellent player let's go bargain
shopping here felder we got jackson hill
who is that's not in the bargain aisle
he's going top 40. he's a special
athlete a special player what do you
like in the bargain aisle for this
jacksonville team maybe on day three of
the draft
it's maybe it's just the chicago because
i'm here and you know i'm going chris
bergen and
linebacker from northwestern one of the
leaders in tackles in the country i
think he led the country in tackles per
game and was like second or third in the
country in total tackles but this is the
guy a little bit under size right he's a
little bit under height but
he ran well at his pro day he tested
well from a vertical standpoint you see
him there flexed out
over the slot so yeah
what do you think about this guy because
i'm watching him i'm like he can play
like i he's gonna be this guy's gonna be
the traditional like i'm a dog and i'll
do anything i can do especially help you
on the four core
felder i love his range and i love his
sub package ability right when you look
at you know bergen you draft him and you
said it about the pro day that came in
that 6593 cone is an elite number and
for those at home that don't know what
the three cone means it's your agility
it's your change of direction and he
might not be uh you know clang and bang
take on blockers i can weave i can beat
you to the sideline you can put him as a
nickel backer to run and take away the
flats and coverage and the thing i love
most about him felder with that athletic
profile he could be a special teams ace
at the nfl level whether it's covering
kicks and punts that ability to run
downfield obviously the mentality as
well so bergen i'm i'm really glad that
is more of a i would say before the pro
day he was challenging to be drafted
because a lot of those guys are priority
udfas to play specials with that
athletic profile yes he's under size but
it doesn't matter that athletic profile
i think somebody's going to use a pick
on them to play specials for them all
right last team of the division the
colts they got matt ryan they are
turning over a new era they're trying to
get over the hump here corner wide
receiver for sure defensive line tied in
felder where are you starting things off
here
i i listen you're the you're the expert
projectionist where do you take justin
ross
one of the toughest ones in the entire
draft if you asked me this question a
couple years ago he was going in the top
40 picks you ask me it now without
knowing medicals
honestly felder i think he's going to be
there in the fourth round i really do
you just hope that you can help him get
his body and his mind right and get back
to the kind of above the rim player that
he showed to be so early on in his
career
well that's the thing for me is watching
him this season and
whether it was a level of contact
shyness or not wanting to make the
contested catches or wanting to play to
the edge more than play to the middle
and like we guess we get a picture here
on a clear slant a clear dig where he's
open in the middle but so much of what
he did was so wide right a lot of back
shoulder not a lot of contested or
or battling and i think we've got a lot
of good shown here but there's also a
lot where he just didn't do a lot of
these things and so that's also a part
of why clemson's often suffered and
obviously the main suffering goes back
to the offensive line there's nothing
you can do about that or there's nothing
that justin ross can do about that
but he doesn't have the same
uh nuke or mike williams or t higgins he
doesn't he doesn't seem to have that
same
makeup
from what we're used to seeing out of
these clemson guys even sammy watkins so
that's an interesting one for me um
another guy i'm going to throw in here
and obviously maybe it's a udfa maybe
it's into the into the end of the draft
sixth seventh round but i'm going to
throw in grant calcutta a guy that was
retired from football from oklahoma
found a new home at smu
i
i loved him coming out of high school
super athletic he plays flexed out he is
truly an f tight end
in terms of his ability to play as that
flexed out option don't want him in line
but i love what he can do when he's
flexed out he's growing as a blocker but
calcaterra at the end of the draft to
give matt ryan something right like i'm
not saying he's kyle pitts but
you know he's
he's got some he's got some ability to
at least stretch the field
yeah felder i think he gets drafted just
to be clear i think he's looking in that
fifth round range which is great for
grant calcutta move tight end big slot
how do you get the ball in his hands and
i think you he showed this year you can
even trust him to block defensive backs
and safeties on the outside especially
in these zone heavy schemes so getting
that senior ball invite was a great sign
for calcutta who's really been able to
remake his career after that medical
retirement you see the projected fits
here felder did some bargain shopping
and did some premium shopping daxton
hill going to the jaguars to kobe dean
to the titans you see canard with the
texans justin ross to the cult let's get
into the comments a little bit before we
sign off here carson nova felder you're
going to love this one he said bring
james cook to deval i know you love that
fit for trevor lawrence
yeah i mean a gadget player that could
do anything
he is someone that just he's one of my
favorite players in this in this in this
group he's
he can flex out he can obviously motion
the cool thing about him is he can line
up in the backfield and then motion out
and there's something different about
lining up in the backfield forcing a
team to move with you which shows their
hand in coverage
opens up the middle of the field and now
you can sneak things in behind so yeah
give give me james cook if you can get
them
all right i'll rip off a couple here and
then we'll sign off uh god eric says if
you waste a pick on bailey zappy i don't
know what to tell you sounds like our
comment section is not a fan of the
quarterbacks the day three quarterbacks
i get it i understand chowder four wants
the colts to take a corner uh more than
a wide receiver after trading rakius in
the colts definitely will be in a
cornerback market if it's got to be
early and we know they don't have a lot
of trap capital this year colts cubs
pacer says the colts are going to win
the division not a bad pick here and the
last one from
erico1981 says the jags will take george
pickens
at 33. felder is that too early for
george pickens or do you like that spot
if
here's the thing if dax hill is if he's
on the board at 33 and you don't take
him you've made a mistake
but if he's off the board now things get
a little more complicated
i don't have a problem with pickings at
33
i like him as a player literally when i
was shooting a video about him i
included the the georgia tech fight in
some blocking clips because he's one of
the few guys that i would call a tone
setter at wide receiver so
i like it it's just a matter of his
health and how you're going to use it
all right
we are once again four weeks away from
the nfl draft as we sit here on another
episode of draft crash course
quarterbacks in the book spell there i
think you and i are happy about that it
is an interesting quarterback year but
not a star-studded quarterback year we
had some fun with the trades as always
we will be back next week 1pm eastern
time here in the bleacher report app i'm
connor rogers from bleacher report he's
michael felder college football analyst
from stadium see ya same time same place
next week
[Music]
you